woran erkenne ich dass du ein endspiel
man erkennt sogar sein sohn jürgen
unangenehm oder in einer charmanten
liebenswürdigen art
ich weiß nicht ich bin doch ungezwungen
fröhlich und lebensbejahend wir reden
heute ich habe den neuen roman von ihnen
regionen maschinen wie ich ein junger
mann kaufte sich einen roboter der sehr
sehr sehr menschlich ist dass der junge
mann und dessen freundin eigentlich
daran erst mal so ein bisschen
verzweifeln
die freundin amüsiert sich schläft mit
dem also er schläft mit ihr und dann
gibt es eine sehr amüsante stelle im
buch wo er so gute konversation macht
mit dem vater der freundin dass dieser
vater ein berühmter schriftsteller
glaubt der roboter wäre eigentlich die
hauptfigur charlie und karriere der
roboter der computerpionier alan turing
spielt eine wichtige rolle in diesem
buch clustering sagt ist wenn die
maschine sich benimmt wie ein mensch
müssen wir ihr auch menschsein zu
schreiben was unterscheidet mensch und
maschine und wieso kann der mensch
existieren
trotz all der widersprüchlichkeiten die
ihr jeden tag wahrnehmen muss etwas
woran die maschinen im wahrsten sinne
des wortes kaputt gehen ja genau
konkret wird es so ganz also bei der
gerechtigkeit ist die maschine die
menschen eigentlich überlegen weil du
kannst bestimmte rigorose moralische
oder ethische kategorien anlegen und die
maschine hält die dann eisern durch mit
einer gewissen unerbittlichkeit sie die
menschen school aller
unterschiedlichkeit dass die menschen
eigentlich daran davon vernichtet werden
richtig aber die andere frage ist ja
worauf können wir uns als menschen
eigentlich noch zurückziehen gegenüber
der maschine was ist unsere eigene
domain ohne dass sich die kreativität
richtig und es ist auch nicht die
intuition sondern für mich ist es das
spiel was ich finde wirklich anders ist
an diesem buch ist die konfrontation von
diesem roboter erdem mit einem kind das
kind ist glaube ich der fundamentale
mensch im kind sind all die
eigenschaften noch vorhanden die den
menschen tatsächlich ausmachen
ich bin eindeutig mensch weil ich habe
eine kognitive dissonanz ich rede mir
die welt so daher wie sie mir gefällt
für mich
ist dieses buch eine sehr unterhaltsame
studie über den unterschied zwischen
menschen und maschinen mit einem sehr
hohen anteil an moral philosophischen
grundsätzen also ich sag das selten aber
es ist wirklich ein wahnsinnig
intelligent das buch schenken wir den
vorhang und schon nächste woche wieder
ran darf ich noch was ganz gut obwohl
das gerade ein sehr schönes ende ein
ende
[Musik]